♪♪
-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-winning
actress
you know from films like
"The Favorite," "Black Widow,"
and "The Constant Gardener."
Her new miniseries,
"Dead Ringers,"
is now streaming
on Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-What is this?
-Hello?
Hello?
-What are you doing?
-Trying to get us the money,
Elliot.
-These are pie charts
and bar graphs.
Did you make these yourself?
-Hello, Mantles?
Feel like I'm losing you.
-How exactly are you planning
on using this, you nerd?
-Mantles?
-Elliot, switch.
-Oh, my God.
You're still just that
14-year-old
wanking into her
algebra homework.
-Um...
-That didn't happen.
-Basically it did.
-But it didn't.
-But it could have.
-Elliot!
-Please welcome to the show,
Rachel Weisz, everybody.
I'm so happy to
have you here.
-Thank you for having me.
-Congratulations on this show.
It's based, loosely based --
it's sort of, I guess,
a new take
on this David Cronenberg film
from 1988, "Dead Ringers."
Do you remember the first time
you saw that film?
-I do. I don't remember, like,
where I was exactly,
but I remember
how it made me feel.
-It's very intense.
-Very intense, very haunting,
twisted.
It's iconic.
It's like an incredible movie.
-But I'm very glad
with the clip you brought
because this show
is both of those things.
It's twisted, it's haunted,
but it's also very funny,
which I am glad that we could
show with the clip,
because I think
when I heard "Dead Ringers"
was going to be
a miniseries, like,
"Oh, I don't know
if I could handle it,"
but it's really -- there's
a lot of humor in this, as well.
Was that very important to you
when you started making this?
-Yes. Yes, it was,
because I think six hours
of that level of intensity
is a lot to ask of someone
at home watching the TV.
Right? Don't you think?
It's a lot. It's a lot.
-You also -- I have to say,
you have great chemistry
with yourself.
-That's so weird
to put it like that.
-There's a lot.
-First of all, I'm very,
just on a technical level,
I'm very impressed
with how well the scenes
where you're acting
against yourself, there is a --
a because you're playing twins,
there's that very, like,
I don't know,
a sibling-type crosstalk
that I would think
would be very hard to do,
considering only one of you
was there at any given time.
-Yeah, well, that's really
distinct characters.
And I had
an acting-scene partner
called Kitty, Kitty Hawthorne,
who was brilliant,
so I wasn't talking to the air.
I had someone to talk to.
-That's very nice.
-Yeah, it was really lovely.
She's brilliant.
And yeah, I mean, they're just
really different people.
So, when you say
chemistry with yourself,
that sounds kind of creepy
and weird.
I mean, I kind of dig it
in a way, but for the show,
for the show,
it was like Elliot's, like --
she's she's very kind
of hungry and slightly...
She's always
kind of moving around,
and she can't eat enough burgers
and sleep with enough guys.
And she's -- and her appetite
for her career is massive.
And Beverly's very kind of shy
and still and thoughtful
and careful.
So, they're just very different.
-It's very easy to yeah,
when you're watching the show,
it's very easy to tell
the two characters apart,
even though they're played
by the --
and you don't have any sort of
like big soap-opera visual cues,
like the eye patch
or anything.
-No, no.
-To know which twin is which.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So I'm very impressed
with that.
-Eye patch, parrot, cane.
Yeah. Yeah.
-Did you have to do --
was it tricky for you?
Was it simple for you
to keep it straight
because the characters
were so divergent?
-Yes. Yes.
They were just
two radically different gals.
Yeah. We learned
to start with Elliot
because she sets the pace,
and she moves around a lot.
And then Beverly would slot in
with her because she's --
she was born two minutes later.
So she's the little sister.
-Yeah. There you go.
It doesn't matter. Birth order.
It doesn't matter how much time.
Birth order matters.
-It matters. Yeah.
-I did not realize.
So, obviously, I was aware
of the Cronenberg film.
I didn't realize
the Cronenberg film
was loosely based
on real-life twins
who were, you know, OB-GYNs
in New York in the '70s.
-Yes.
-Were you aware of that?
-Yes. There was a big
"New York" magazine article,
which I read about them.
Yeah. They were both found dead
in their apartment.
They, I think -- well,
one of them OD'd.
But they were
the celebrity doctors
to get your baby delivered by
if you were a woman
with a certain amount
of wealth in 1973.
You wanted these guys
to deliver your babies.
And funnily enough,
the apartment block
where we filmed in Manhattan
that was the lobby of the twins'
home in the TV show,
the woman who managed
the building came up to me
and she said,
"I was delivered
by one of those doctors."
-Wow.
-Which was kind of uncanny
and strange, anyway,
that we should cross paths.
But yeah.
-What a trip.
-I know, right? I know.
-I heard for preparation,
you know,
for playing these characters
who had this professional skill,
you actually watched
some childbirths happen?
-Yes.
-Obviously you got permission.
-I did. I did.
-Okay.
-I did.
-That's very good.
On an H.R. level, I had to ask.
-Yeah.
Imagine just like hiding behind
a potted plant, you know.
-And the doctor being like,
"We're going to
put you under some anesthesia.
"You might see
an Academy Award winner.
That's totally normal.
That's not a real thing."
I mean, obviously you've
been on the other side of it.
What did you feel like
watching it?
I mean, I will say because one
of the things this show does,
because we see almost everything
on television, it's so rare
that we see a very realistic
depiction of childbirth,
which I will say as someone
who went into watching --
you know, I've seen
all three of my kids get born
in all very different locations,
I should note.
Hospital, lobby, and bathtub.
So, I've seen them all,
but I wish I'd seen more of it
before I saw it
for the first time
because watching it is -- you
just watch it and you're like,
"Well, this is obviously
going wrong."
-Yes.
Yeah, It looks scary, right?
-I mean, so, I mean,
having -- you obviously
had gone through it.
Was watching it --
were you like,
"Oh, is that
what it looked like?"
-It's a really good question.
Yeah, of course, when you're
giving birth yourself, it's...
Yeah, you don't know.
You're sort of...
Yeah, it's very intense.
It's very intense.
You can't see it.
Yeah. So, you'd witnessed it...
-Yeah.
...from the outside.
-Yeah, that would be a weird
case where I'd go, like,
"As a man,
let me tell you what..."
-Yeah, it was exhilarating,
actually.
I shadowed some obstetricians,
and that was the technical term.
I wasn't behind them
looking creepy like, but...
But I shadowed these
obstetricians and it was,
I suppose
the simplest way to say it is
that I know that it happens
every second on planet Earth.
Someone's being born.
But to actually witness it,
it was exhilarating.
I had an adrenaline rush
the likes
of which I'd never had,
and it seemed like a miracle.
It seemed like
this miraculous thing.
There's a human being
coming out of another.
It's extraordinary.
Absolutely.
Is that how you felt when...
-I did.
You know, you also think
the next one you'll be,
you know...
-Used to it.
-Right.
And you aren't at all.
I mean, it's held --
I do feel like my wife
has done a nice job
of heightening each time.
So, I do appreciate it.
-You mean like the dangerous
places where she --
-Yeah, I mean, she's, like,
kind of a thrill mom, you know?
-Yeah, I love that.
It's like you've done
the lobby.
What's next?
-What's next?
-Yeah, I love that.
-But yeah, you kind of...
And it's just
that thing of like,
there wasn't -- like a minute
ago there wasn't a human being.
And now it's here.
And then it dawns on you.
And you've got to take care
of it forever.
-The rest of your life.
-Yeah.
-But, you know,
it must have been...
I know you're a producer
on this, as well,
so I have to imagine there were
a great amount of conversations
about the care you took
with trying to depict this
in a way that was,
you know, I don't know.
I mean, obviously,
it's entertainment,
but it is like helpful
to put this on screen,
I think, in a way
that it hasn't been before.
-Yeah.
I mean, I think Alice Birch,
the showrunner and writer
extraordinaire of the piece,
she and I just felt like
it was really interesting
to show childbirth.
We're so used to seeing
violence on the screen.
Like, there's such
a cinematic language now
for the ways in which
you can die --
operatically comedically,
tragic, you know,
blood spurting, you know,
we're just so used to it.
But there's something about,
yeah,
childbirth that seemed like,
yeah, there is some blood,
but it's beautiful
and interesting.
-Yeah.
-And it's, you know,
it's the kind
that you actually one day
will be hopefully lucky
to see, right?
Like, it's the good kind. So.
-Yeah.
-I know that --
-What do you mean?
-Well...
-Sorry.
-You're not allowed
to ask follow-ups of me.
-Okay. Sorry. Okay.
-No, what I mean, I guess,
is when you watch,
like, a gunshot violence
on a TV show,
like, you hope in real life,
you hope you'll never
encounter that.
But when you see
the sort of, you know,
I don't want to say there's
the violence of childbirth,
but it does like feel like --
-It's intense.
-It's a lot. It's a lot.
-So, it's actually an intense
thing that being able
to see realistically depicted
on a television show
is like a helpful thing
to see once before you see it.
-I think
that's really beautifully put.
-Well, it took some time.
We got there.
-Yeah.
-Much like childbirth,
we got there.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Well, it's high stakes.
-It's high stakes.
-It's the highest stakes,
most dramatic moment
in a human being's life.
And for the mom,
the dad, the baby.
-The crazy thing is how, I mean,
it's high stakes
for the obstetricians,
but they also have to --
the fact
that they do it multiple times
in the same day.
-Yeah, it's just...
-It just blows my mind.
-Yeah.
For them, I guess it's ordinary
at this point.
-You have to make it ordinary,
like, you don't want one of them
being like, "Oh, no!"
-"Whoa!"
-"Oh, this is bad!"
-We'd make
a good obstetrician pair.
Like, "Whoa!"
-"Oh!"
-"Whoo!"
-One of the other things,
the last thing I'll say,
it must have been nice that,
you know, you make movies
all over the world.
You actually got to work
on the show in your hometown.
Was that the best?
-It was the best.
I was at Silvercup Studios,
Long Island City,
and it was just -- yeah,
it was so great
to be in New York
and all the crew,
all the technicians
are just so fantastic here.
And I loved it. I loved it.
-It's a really wonderful show.
It's so beautifully directed.
The art design on this show
is just gorgeous
and you're really
wonderful in it.
And thanks so much
for being here to talk about it.
-Thank you, Seth.
Thank you.
-Rachel Weisz, everybody.
All six episodes
of "Dead Ringers"
are available now
on Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪